let's talk about your story first with
uh with getting canceled so people can
understand what Comics gate is and uh
why they should they should hear your
story because I know a lot of people may
not be familiar uh where did my where'd
my pen go is it this one that is awesome
so uh basically you are responsible for
some of the most iconic uh comic book
imagery I like that I don't know if it's
true but I yeah well so so you created
Flash's mother Nora well that's one
thing yeah I know right but hold on the
movie that's coming out The Flash movie
yeah it's about him going back to save
his mom is it not right I think so yeah
Flashpoint Paradox that's a a major DC
storyline right where the flash his
mother was killed by zoom and then he
wants to go back in time because he can
run so fast he can do it so this is a
character you created now so influential
there's a major massive you know
Blockbuster film about to be released I
think that's that's important context
people to understand the amount of
influence you've had on the industry is
is large Plus in the in the video game
that came out a few years ago Injustice
two atrocitus is a character who is in
it you can play as him a character that
you you drew you created the art for uh
yeah I created the whole thing I'll take
a hundred percent credit for atrocities
yeah I just I had the name I said this
is so DC Comics atrocitus it sounds
great so you actually created the
character absolutely yeah and then one
day you said hey everybody I voted for
Trump and they then they they came after
you well they they knew I was a
republican I mean they did I I used
stood I mean I literally was the only
elephant in the room all the time when I
went to comic book conventions and
everybody looked at me weird uh I would
have friends I would make friends with
other professionals uh and then uh I
would I I don't know we'd spend a little
time apart and then the next time I'd
see them they'd go
you voted for Bush
and they'd have this look of disgust
about them that I was like yes I'm a
republican I voted if I voted for Bush
uh and then that was fine I think the
Obama years were great because uh for me
anyway because uh I wasn't being
persecuted I did nobody was worried
about anything because Obama was
President they won uh and Trump was a
joke I really didn't think much of trump
in 2015 but he won me over by 2016 and I
was a fan and I love the Pepe memes I
loved all that stuff uh so uh anyway it
was no big deal until Trump actually won
and when Trump won I just thought great
it's our turn you know very naive about
the culture War were my Maga hat that
was autographed by the president and I
took a nice picture and I tweeted it out
and that's when I started to see I
started to see messages from my peers
saying things like Ethan's Maga Ethan
Vince givers Maga did you see that yeah
well I guess he's canceled now right
everybody he's canceled and I didn't
know what that was all about but there
was definitely like rage over this idea
uh that somebody who was a fairly
influential artist at DC Comics was a
trump supporter and uh I didn't think it
was gonna you know I basically talked to
a few of them and kind of said hey this
is the way oh God I'm so naive I said
this is the way the country moves
forward right step left step you know
basically we all get our turn and
hopefully you know this is progress
but then I got a message from somebody
who said
how could you do this you voted against
all of your queer comrades and Comics
how do you understand that our lives are
in are in Jeopardy and you voted for
that don't you care
and I guess I wrote back to that person
and I kind of said uh well uh I guess I
don't care that much about that I guess
I have a priorities in my life then you
know you're we all have our different
you know issues that we vote on uh
anyway my response to that tweet or that
private message got shared around to all
my peers and now everybody was furious
with me because I'd basically
invalidated the lives of my queer
Associates and Comics uh and then the
final thing was I was persecuted of
people were coming after me
um
I had a writer I was working with on
Batman I was doing Batman for a little
while this great guy named Greg hurwitz
and he had a mutual friend he had a uh
Jordan B Peterson was his friend and he
kind of said have you heard of this guy
Jordan Peterson I said yes he's great
you know well he's seen your work he
likes it he wants to know if you'll
illustrate his upcoming book and uh I
was just like well if I do that if I do
it I'm gonna get a weapon I know it you
know that's going to be a big problem
I'm already on the verge of cancellation
I was terrified uh my wife and I just
had a baby who was diagnosed with autism
and so I needed my job I really needed
my job but on the other hand I had this
conversation with Jordan Peterson
where he said something that really
impacted me and I still think about this
every single day and it helps me step
forward it helps me take another step he
said Ethan I said I'm scared Dr Peterson
I'm scared to illustrate your book
and he just said uh Ethan you can't let
these mobbers back you into a corner I
wish I could do a Canadian accent for
you you can't let these mobbers back you
into a corner and I just thought to
myself
you're damn right you know I'm gonna
illustrate your book and so I did I
Illustrated 12 rules for life it turned
out to be a number one bestseller and
that was it I have the uh someone sent
me the Korean version really yeah I
guess it was a joke
I can't read Korean though it may have
burned some bridges or seems to have it
that it launched your career in so many
other ways that book is huge it was it
was big but again it wasn't really my
book it was Jordan Peterson's book and
people just kind of incidentally go oh
your name's in that like my little
sister Hannah who's a big fan of yours
she's watching right now hi Hannah howdy
uh you know she she was shocked she's
like we love that book I can't believe
my brother Illustrated it like I just
you know so um uh in any case like that
it's more stuff like that but what it
really did was it just kind of like set
my feet in stone like I am now
officially I guess a culture Warrior
where I didn't even believe the culture
War existed until then wow uh and here
was this 2017 2017. and I said people
were calling me a white supremacist and
a Nazi and all these things that in 2017
really hurt you didn't want to be called
a Nazi you didn't want people to think
you were racist and but those are the
weapons that they use against creative
people and pretty much anyone the that
they want to destroy nobody you can't
deny that you're racist it's racism is
on a spectrum so is white supremacy and
If you deny it that proves it in in a
sense yes it does the cockatrap you're
not even aware that you're racist let me
explain why you're racist so really is a
a nasty situation and um
in any case uh DC Comics called me up
and it was uh I gotta say DC did the
best they could but they were being
swarmed by the media uh over my
existence working there the thing that
leftists do that they're so great at uh
is they have accomplices in the media
that will write the articles that you
want them to write that they want them
to write and then those will get
published on The Daily Beast or any of
these awful like websites uh and then
they'll refer to those articles as proof
that you are exactly who they say you
are and then those get referenced in
Wikipedia your Wikipedia is soon
denouncing you as a whatever it is so a
white supremacist or whatever they're
calling you uh and uh anyway
um so that was uh that was that DC
Comics called me up and God bless them
they they tried to stand by me as much
as they could but uh somebody who I
really like their friend of the family
called me up and I said am I okay is
everything okay and I could hear him
pouring a drink into a little glass I
could hear the ice and he just said we
can't renew your contract wow and uh he
took a big drink and I was like I have a
child I have a baby I have a baby with
autism I need my job and he said well
you've got four or five more issues on
your contract and then that's it we
gotta you got time to find other work
you know
so it was absolutely terrifying you know
you know what the mistake he made was
what well you see with the you know the
left would a leftist would have done
what they would have immediately started
yelling how dare you touch me you ever
you ever watch Fight Club yes you know
the scene where Edward Norton falls on
the ground that's punching himself in
the face yeah that's what the left does
yeah so then they walk out and then
people are like I saw him walk out with
a black eye and then you're like you're
gonna renew my content that's what they
do cry bullies right they say they they
they accuse the boss of some kind of
impropriety they exploit the law the
EEOC uh the labor rights and stuff like
that whereas you and on the sky just
went well I guess my contract's gone I
guess I'll leave yeah but you know one
thing I don't like is when people use
the word can't that's really annoying
when when what it means is I don't want
to we don't want to but we're like we
can't refer your contract no they could
they just chose not to they could have
but who am I I mean they were DC Comics
was in all kinds of trouble they were
trying to sign with the ATM I'm making
excuses for them they were trying to
sell themselves to ATT they were trying
to get good press and they were
deliberately the left was deliberately
putting all this stuff in the media to
make it look like they were employing
white supremacists they really didn't
have as a business a choice and I I give
them a pass I do because they were
they've always been good to my family up
until the end and they're still writing
me big royalty checks for movies like
The Flash that are wow really yeah
that's cool that's nice yeah yeah that's
fine with a t for like a year and
they're eating sold again yeah so I I
don't don't answer this if you can't I'm
curious
maybe you can answer in a more General
sense you know
so the flat with The Flash movie you're
getting like a royal tier from that
somehow I'll bet yeah so I'm like how
does that I I want to avoid asking
anything too personal I'm curious like a
comic book artist who sees their work
turn into a movie like what kind of
money can they make from that is it like
a big deal is it like you're gonna buy a
mansion or is it like you might pay a
phone bill oh oh no we bought our house
from the Justice League royalties so
from the movie yeah yeah wow thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time